now we have news that another pharmacy
is starting to administer vaccines right
here in southern nevada
joe mohler has more details for us on
that and the new second
dose site in fact that's where he's live
tonight at the las vegas convention
center
joe if you received your first dose from
one of the health district locations you
will get your second dose here at the
las vegas convention center starting
next tuesday now earlier today the
health district released some more
information about
the vaccination efforts happening here
in clark county more than one hundred
thousand vaccines have been administered
so far
many people have reached out to me
asking about the second dose
after receiving the first at cashman
center now the health district started
contacting people
this week to set up the second
appointment at the convention center
so be on the lookout if you are
expecting that
some of the pharmacies are receiving
vaccine and their target population is
70 and up
and walgreens and cvs have started
appointments and more are to come
save on is is coming on smith's is also
an option and you can reach those
appointments
at nevadakovidfighter.org
right now the health district has
allocated twenty two thousand to twenty
three thousand vaccines
a week but today they said they do have
the capacity to administer around four
times that so they are hoping
to get more in the near future now back
out here live doses here will be
administered at
central hall dedicated parking is
available in the silver lot off paradise
road and convention center drive
so if you believe you should have been
contacted by the convention
by the southern nevada health district
by now you are urged to reach out to
them we also have information regarding
booking appointments on our website that
is 8newsnow.com
reporting live here at the las vegas
convention center joe mullen 8 news now
jose